counter-terror police in Manchester
England made a new arrest overnight in
the bomb investigation fifteen-year-old
Megan Hurley is the latest victim killed
in the attack to be named her brother
was reportedly injured by the blast and
that means all 22 people who died have
been identified
armed police patrolled a major London
transit hub as part of a big security
boost around Britain Mark Phillips is in
Manchester with new details of the
investigation mark good morning
good morning well this is day four of
raids and rests as police try to unravel
what they say is the network behind the
bombing and they say they're making
progress except of course that the
security threat level that's still
hanging over the country is critical
this time it's a barber shop in an area
of South Manchester where the bomber
lived police cut their way into the shop
early this morning and have been taking
material away this might have been a
laptop another merchant in the area says
Salman Abadi the suspected bomber was
seen from time to time at the barbers
talking with other people the combat
mission tilden he came the irregular
Salman baby yeah he used to be near the
shop had been suspiciously empty since
the bombing what was once a normal
neighborhood says resident luis Cottman
isn't anymore I'm just amazed like how
one one night everything is fine and the
next next day out is something so cool
speechless don't know what to see after
another arrest overnight police were
holding eight people but they are still
not sure the terror network including
it's presumed bomb-making capacity has
been neutralized but the sense of
anxiety continues in the latest move
armed police have been placed on some
trains more it seems as a
confidence-building measure that in
response to a specific threat that's
spat by the way between British and US
intelligence officers over the leaking
of intelligence gathered here to the
American press is over Manchester police
now say they are sharing intelligence
again and this is the big long holiday
weekend here major sporting events a big
outdoor rock concert big crowds life
getting back to normal except of course
it's not charlie Mark Phillips in
Manchester thanks